okay for people joining this meeting
this
is a continuation of design discussion
about chemistry functionality
wolverine language version 12.3
uh okay so i'm seeing here improvements
to molecule draw a new plot themes for
molecule plot 3d
are after 12 3 okay so
what we looked at here
last time was i thought this had been
renamed
already it has it's now a molecule
identifier lookup
so i just grayed out the bullet points
that we touched on
rather than fully updating them okay all
right
so um okay so the first
thing here is
molecule substructure count
that the first thing i should look at
here yes it should be relatively
easy to say yes or no to um not terribly
exciting but useful
uh when next fine molecule substructure
or molecule contains q
okay i'm not buying i mean if it's fine
molecule substructure why isn't molecule
substructure cases
do you understand what i'm saying why
isn't molecule substructure
otherwise known if this is molecule if
if this is
if this is counting what fine molecule
substructure finds
right then this shouldn't be a find
and someone i'm saying i do i do um
yeah i hadn't thought of that when we i
so i just
based it off of find a graph isomorphism
when we were
designing that
um
i think the reason it's called fine
growth of graph isomorphism
is because it may fail can your fine
molecule substructure fail
yes if the if this if it's not there no
no no
that's not what i mean that's not what i
mean find graph isomorphism
i believe there are isomorphic graphs
that it will not determine isomorphism
for
do you understand what i'm saying i
think there's a
i think we changed this
i think there's a isomorphic graph cue
right oh god we've still got this
stupid thing going here
okay so i can't really trust anybody
else to send this message correctly i
have to do it myself
okay okay why is this called find
graphic
okay finds an isomorphism it maps the
graph by renaming vertices so can this
fail or not
apparently not maybe find cycle is
better
equivalent because
there's more objects with the parallel
to molecules
okay but find molecule substructure you
believe if there is substructure it will
find it correct
yes it's not heuristic it's not anything
else it will find it
so i didn't write the algorithm myself
so i can't guarantee that
yeah i understand that but in principle
it will find it yes
okay
and it will find it in the form that
fine graph isomorphism does
where it's telling you the mapping from
one molecule to the other is that
correct
yes
so and then molecule contains q
i see it essentially returns
whether or not that would return an
empty list
without uh populating that return
yeah yeah
seems okay to me this seems okay to me
no it's an operator form that represents
it's how you have to write that right
you you know just go look at someplace
else how to do it
right that's not correct um
i don't know why you pick such an
incredibly you know look
i gotta comment on this okay this isn't
the way these examples should work
there should not be two steps it's going
to be one step
okay am i making sense
right so do you understand this don't
ever do it this way
it's it's we tried to okay
this is broken for many different
reasons
right we don't want to have to show you
know it doesn't copy properly if you
have two steps like this
and it also is more difficult to
understand
so just pick a molecule that's short
enough stick it in there
stick it in there again am i making
sense
yes okay fine and please make sure you
don't do this thing
of defining something you know that's a
very expensive operation
examples to define something and then
use it later
so if you know you only do that if you
really really really have to
that make sense yes okay
okay
molecule value plot
right so uh i rather like these uh
functions in the
that were put in the function repository
but they could very easily i think uh
be system functions i think that's a
good idea yes they seem like a good idea
to me
i mean they seem like except we don't
really have graph
value plot
i mean we have that i think as a in the
function repository but i don't think
we've ever put that
and that will be something that will be
worth thinking through how that works
do you see what i'm saying right right i
mean it could use any type of a
vertex or edge annotation in the same
way
well can you do edge annotations here
no no so i i think of bond type and i
think of
atomic number as being vert edge and
vertex annotations
uh in the sense so in that sense
you could do the same thing with a graph
yeah these do seem like very sensible
functions
um i mean is this a 12 3 type story or
is this something beyond that
uh so this would be for 12 3 i could uh
so i would make
um let's see so before unfuturizing a
doc page i would i would
uh we could meet again when i convert
this over to a
title so something like this isn't going
to cut it
yeah i mean there's some stuff like this
isn't going to cut it you need to have
your own
you know i mean starry night colors
isn't a
isn't a you know right so it should be i
mean by default automatic and i can
check with uh with brett or with someone
uh
to see what the the proper default value
automatic value should be yes and also
you might need somebody from design to
work on
colors if if that is part of the story
um
and i mean the way this legending works
that will need to be developed
right so you have freedom about how that
works
okay i mean that might be a default but
it can't be the only thing that can
happen
right so i mean so it should take the
the legending spec i mean so
uh yes yeah yeah all the usual stuff
what does this exclusion function do uh
so let's see so for example when you
want to look at
atom chirality the majority of them will
be none
two or three might be r or s and it's
the rrs that you care about
um so it tells you so why aren't you
just having it be the case that if it's
none
then you just don't include it and i
mean it's like
look the way that should work is like
color function
color color rules right color rules
if there's a if you don't specify the
rules for a particular
thing it isn't rendered
right i was looking at this all of the
use cases i have for the exclusion
functions
remove either missing or none values so
we should just we could just remove
those by default
i would say so it seems right to me and
if you want to do this by hand
but look i think you do want something
where
you can give
uh let's take a look at how this
compares to geo region value plot
okay
oh gosh this drives me crazy what
exactly is this doing
it's really stupid whatever it's doing
what is it doing here can you see what
it's doing
i mean
it's really dumb look at this it's in
that state
and then it goes to this state but it
has this wave which somebody must have
thought was very clever
okay
so the analog here would be
atom specification arrow value
right yes
do we already have something that does
something like that or not
so no so i mean uh let's see some yes we
do we have that we have the thing that
highlights molecules right
right so in so you could have molecule
plot comma
mal or molecule plot first argument
molecule
and then the second argument uh a list
of atom indices
with possibly with a style wrapper okay
okay fine so that's what does that
and that's essentially what molecule
value plot is doing
it's called it's it's making an
appropriate molecule plot call
so why isn't molecule pluck just taking
these second arguments
because so the second argument of
molecular plot already does a lot of
work
um so it can take patterns it can take
uh
so it can already take a string and and
uh take it to be a pattern i believe
uh well what kind of a pattern uh
smiles well let's find out what it does
oh man i hope that wasn't wrong on that
one
yeah it's just for highlighting uh
substructures
okay so that's different
from this okay so molecule plot takes a
pattern
where these things are highlighted right
right
okay so what this is doing is
it is applying this function
so in order to get okay
in order to get these partial charges
for every atom how do you do that
uh make a molecule value call
so you say molecule value of the
molecule
comma these things and so what's the
difference between molecule plot
of molecule value of blah blah blah
in in a molecular plot where the second
argument is molecule value of that thing
so molly so let's see so
right now molecule value plot knows that
the second thing can be a property and
so knows to go and look for properties
molecule plot
wants the second argument to either be a
pattern and it's going to say
and it's going to look are you a smarts
pattern i i understand i understand did
you understand my question
so my question was if i put as that
second argument
molecule value
the molecule comma one of these things
right so so let's say i have the
molecule there is
caffeine and you're gonna have to wrap
that in molecule
why
why let's see
did you understand my question i do
understand your question you
you think that everything that takes a
molecule should take anything that would
make a molecule i think so
and so i haven't uh implemented that
okay all right
i think you should look at that and see
if there's a problem with that idea but
if there isn't i think you should make
it work
but okay so these are the charges by
atom number right
right and so now at this point then uh
you need you would need to
uh calculate a color for each of those
numbers
and then the sec the thing that you
would feed to molecule plot would be the
molecule and then a list of
style vertex number
color okay okay so so here among
the other things okay so you've got a
color function here although you
probably also want to color rules
here do you understand what i'm saying
so we use
molecule plot uses color rules to
determine carbon is this
uh nitrogen is that i understand it's a
molecule value plot
also presumably needs a color rules
to determine how it will color something
which says
it's a this or it's a that right
right right so it really it should take
all of the i mean it should take all of
the options the molecule plot takes in
fact
yeah but wait a second it's got a
molecule plot going on underneath
but the whole point is its color rules
refer
not to the color of carbon but to the
color of the annotations
right okay
is what i'm saying right right
right because yes yes because so it's
the same idea
as with with highlight graph highlight
graph
in the highlight you can have a graph
which has its own
color specifications but then highlight
graph refers to the colors of the
highlights
you see what i'm saying yes okay that's
how this should work i think
although i don't know what the base
colors of the molecule should be in that
case
so um in the examples here i make them
them all black i know i can see that but
i'm asking you if if you wanted if you
had base colors to the molecule
and then some piece of the molecule
wants to get annotated for highlight
graph
it's preserving where it can the base
colors of the graph
and then overwriting them where it needs
to
did you understand what i'm saying yes
okay so that's what i'm saying needs to
happen
it needs to be possible here as well
okay
um i think you yan you might want to
mute yourself i'm going to meet you
um so i can
uh take this feedback and make and uh uh
make a
system doc page for this function you
should yes i think it's nice okay
but let me just make a couple of other
comments here so
so if we look at geo region value plot
okay
it has
see i'm wondering here whether
its notion of property is with an arrow
right it has a region and then an
arrow
which the geographic subdivisions in
region are
colored according to this you see what
i'm saying
so if i say
if i were to say for example
um
i don't know this works but maybe it
does arrow
gdp does that work
so i feel like uh um wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait let's
understand what that thing is
in which the geographic subdivisions in
region are color according to this
does anybody know how this works this is
not showing that case
ah
oh gosh
that's something that shouldn't be able
to happen
that might be hard by the way
by the way i just want to comment who's
project managing here
who's this menu okay so
the font for that progress monitor is
wrong the font is too big and it's too
dark
um i this is now the third time i
pointed out the same thing
all right okay so look at what this is
doing
so this is the analog of molecule arrow
and then
did you get what i'm saying this is the
analog of what you're doing here
yes
now the difference is that this has a
syntax where it's
giving individual regions individual
values
right molecule value plot could have a
syntax whereas
the second argument is a list of rules
of
index goes to value um
how wouldn't that be the same as
molecule plot then well no so then you
still have molecule value plot looking
at all the values and
you're getting an appropriate range
applying the color function
and then how does it relate to molecule
plot doesn't molecule part
you said molecule plot second argument
is right the
molecule plot second argument is a
pattern i see
but it doesn't have what happens if i
want to specify that different elements
of that pattern should be colored
differently
so you can specify a um so you can
specify the second argument for molecule
plot uh
as a list of indices as the pattern
like no i i understand that but if i
want one index colored red and another
you know
the substructure that is the first
substructure in
pat colored red the second one colored
green etc how do i do that
so you can wrap them wrap the
substructures in style
and give it uh doesn't say that anywhere
here
so please fix the documentation yes
okay also this should show a list form
here
yes okay
and i assume i can wrap it with with
call outs and who knows what else
as well right that's what i want to work
on next
so call out doesn't work no style works
but call out does not
right okay but you need to document that
here
okay so
the concept here molecule value plot
would be
it's a perfectly sensible concept that
each thing here
instead of it just being a highlight it
is
giving a value
and so then then the form will be very
much the same as this
except the first argument would be a
molecule
or you could give molecule arrow and
then a property
and it would compute that property for
each element of the molecule
just like it does here does that make
sense
yes
okay i think it's a good function then
and the results are very beautiful
all right thank you let's keep going
right lovely okay let's keep going
those were supposed to be the easy ones
indeed
you know anyway okay molecular line
so we just started looking at this one
last time if i remember correctly i feel
like i have to warn you that
with a lot of the examples we felt the
need to create the molecules show them
before alignment and then
align them and show them after yeah
we'll do
that another way to do that just don't
do that just don't do that
just just do look look
just don't do it this way just repeat
for goodness sake what are you doing
here import of whatever
what i don't understand what this is so
in this case you need two different
versions of the same molecule with
different coordinates in order to align
them
one of them comes from a file and one of
them comes from uh
out from thin air or one is created on
the spot
and so they therefore have different
coordinates okay
this is a really garbagey way to do this
okay
so
if you're gonna do this see see the
mistake you keep on making is
your examples are too complicated i mean
if you're going to do this
to show aligning molecules just take
water
you don't need something complicated
like this do you
no okay so well i mean water is planar
but uh
so specific i mean okay right fine
whatever
something non-planar but methane right
yes
right and what you should do then
you can rotate one of the groups for
instance then
align that and what i would do is use an
use i can eyes for example if you want
to give one of these things don't do
this
do you see what i'm saying okay okay i
so i was well alternatively
alternatively you could just give
well let's see what does the molecule
give what does this give if you read it
in
so it would all evaluate to a summary
box with uh with the molecule in it
um so i didn't know if that was
preferable to having the import call
yes it is preferable okay much
preferable
yeah so just use that molecule
yeah i mean just use it for both of them
you don't need to show
that what you're trying to show okay
look look
okay technical writing you know
thing here okay you're just
trying to show one thing you're not
trying to show eight things at the same
time
right the thing you're trying to show is
how you align molecules correct
yes okay so then what it should show
is none of this stuff nothing none of
what's there right
nothing nothing of that type right so
this
would presumably say the first thing it
should say
is molecule a line of and then you can
take these molecules
if you want to
okay what is that it's the aligned
result uh
stephen the difficulty with this is that
by comparison to something mathematical
let's say you want to take
last of a list you you give it the list
one two three you say last you get the
result
three you can see the beginning and the
end very clearly
here we're dealing with
three-dimensional geometries and we
don't get to see the three-dimensional
geometry we're starting from
unless we explicitly call that out
somehow with molecule plot 3d
i understand what you're trying to do
here but you know we're kind of
hamstrung
uh so here's what i would do here's what
i would do
i would do this
you can't use that as input though
and and how do we see that this has had
non-standard
that this has coordinates specified
very messily no no no no but here's what
i think you should do
okay this has no coordinates specified
right
great okay so the first thing is in this
box here and i'm not saying this for
this particular example
but in general you should say
coordinates
sp you know and then paren in gray
specified or something
you see what i'm saying i do or leave
them out right because that way we'd
know
that there's something special about
that
it's a very good idea i like that a lot
okay so
all right so the issue here is
the alignment is a re-coordinating
molecule
correct yes
okay and and i assume what's happening
is that the second molecule is being
aligned to the first molecule
correct correct correct okay so the
return
thing if if what i did was i tried to
align water
to this what would happen
in other words presumably i can align a
fragment
right so uh so it would probably tell
you so it should tell you that it did
not find
uh the reference the first argument as a
substructure in water
which is something i think jason we need
to work on
what
because what stephen has just asked for
you know
we we can't do we can't move water onto
something bigger
we can move something uh bigger onto
something smaller the way it's currently
set up
oh yeah that's right i should be able to
understand i mean uh
so what would what would it mean to want
to align water onto something
you know find a place where you can
align it like let's say this is carbon
i don't know what that is that's there
isn't anything there there's i mean
there's an example further down that
that shows uh
menthol being aligned on top of a susque
terpene uh which is this one here
the blue one is the substructure of the
yellow one
so but in general if you weren't able to
find that and map it onto it
sorry sorry for talking over you i mean
if you want to align water to something
then you need to specify
the the atom mapping between water and
the and what you want to align it to
well okay hold on if if
if i'm understanding correctly if there
is a substructure i don't know what you
call it it's not a
you know a little you know a something
ring you know a a
um a aromatic ringy thing
what are those called just just a a
piece of a molecule what are those
called
the r thingies what are those what are
the two do i like substitute
substructures
okay fine all right so if i want to
align a substructure onto a molecule
this is the function to do that is that
right
yes okay so in other words if i have a
great big molecule
and i say where does this aromatic ring
fit on this molecule this is the
function i would want to use
correct i don't think no it doesn't
it doesn't necessarily do the find you
you
generally know where you want to put it
in some cases
you can expect it to find the unique
place where it would go but if there are
multiple places they could go
then you know um you know
in this example here there are two
different six-membered rings where just
a six-membered ring could map
absolutely so i would expect this
function
so you want to return two different
online thinking i mean how would you do
that otherwise
or is that fine molecule substructure
fine molecule substructure is
topological it just considers the the
atoms and bonds and this is
three-dimensional
right i mean this is the function you
call after you've already called my
fine molecule substructure and you know
the the corresponding
atom indices so this function molecule
align its
primary purpose is so that you don't
have to extract out the points
the the mapped points take those points
feed them to find geometric transform
get the geometric transform
come back to your molecule and apply
that to the to the whole risk
of the coordinates uh that's the primary
so wait a minute so so hold on so i mean
if you have molecules which are
sort of zippered together at a
particular place like they have these
two
i don't know molecules really but i mean
if they have these two aromatic rings
and those are aligned but they have
tentacles that are hanging off in
different ways
is that what you would be able to do
with this function
yes you could align the two rings and
see the tentacles hanging off in
different directions
what what do you mean by the word are
aligned
no if you want to to align them that is
you've got these two molecules
and they agree by having they have an
aromatic ring
somewhere and they've got tentacles
which are maybe different yeah
and then you say align these molecules
and align it
at the position of that that's what this
function is for
yep okay but the generic case of this
function
i see
wait a minute what's this uses the
molecule pattern i don't understand what
that means
so in that case the pattern could be a
molecule pattern for a six-membered ring
okay so that's saying at which place to
try to do the alignment
right so it so the pe so the pattern is
used to generate the uh
the the list of uh rules between adam
indices and then i understand that
if all i did was i had a disembodied
six-membered ring
why wouldn't i want to just say you know
i've got this reference molecule
and it's got a whole complicated
structure with lots of coordinates
now i've got a disembodied six-member
ring tell me where in
in that first molecule's coordinate
space that six-membered ring would align
do you understand what i'm saying kind
of i mean but
but oftentimes you might want to know i
mean where does this what kind of pocket
does this go into or something and
that's not what this function would do
right this no but what stephen is asking
for the
the fine substructure would find the
different
uh topological mappings and then you
would use a line to see which one
in three dimensions gave you the best
geometric exactly alignment between the
atoms
exactly that with this yes
so i'm suggesting is
you know you do the topological thing
off you know
as automatically here if i give you a
reference molecule like this
this caf whatever this is aspirin
and then i give you a six-membered ring
right a pure disembodied six-member ring
just six carbons here
okay and then i say molecular line what
i would like to get back out
is a version of my six you know six
carbon atoms
with coordinates that where the burnt in
coordinates
align with this ring here does that make
sense
yes and and the six membered ring you
give it would have to have its own
coordinates and you would get the
the difference between them in terms of
a root mean squared
why why does it have to have its own
coordinates because this is a
three-dimensional
operation okay i understand but but you
could
lay that out i mean by default
in many cases just use whatever molecule
plot 3d would do
for those coordinates okay
in if a structure is provided without
coordinates they do get generated
automatically
but generally this function is used when
both
moving and reference molecules have
geometries and that's what you're
you're interested in comparing okay i
understand but there's a simpler case
here
where you know well that isn't true and
so so for example let's say we have a
planar version of this ring i've got
it's got coordinates but the coordinates
are in la la land and then what i want
to do is to burn in the coordinates
which were appropriate for this
particular aspirin here
from the reference molecule exactly
okay i see what you're asking for and
that's a very
that is a a different task it's more
like a transfer
yeah i don't understand why isn't it the
exact same task
molecular line as i understand it
it it keeps the molecule rigid it
doesn't
i know okay but you wanted to inherit
something from the other
no i don't no i don't i want to keep it
rigid i want to keep it rigid
but you want to move it on top of the
reference one
and if it doesn't have a geometry give
it a standard geometry before you move
it
that's what i'm saying yes yeah like but
but then
still like if you give the standard
geometry it will not fit perfectly
that's correct that's why this is an
alignment not a yes
that's why you're quoting root mean
square minimum root mean square
and if there were two rings and one of
them was bent
and the default you know flat
version of that ring didn't fit the bent
ring then it would tell you
it will most likely align on the unbent
one
does that make sense i mean i understand
that the most common case
i mean but what i'm saying is that
there's a substructure
that okay you could have a complete
second molecule as a second thing
and then it will this here is saying
where it aligns right yes
right i don't think you should have to
give the
i see i see is the molecule pattern so
this is just telling it
molecule pattern that this isn't clear
does that pattern apply to mole or to
ref
to both right because they try it but it
doesn't but it shouldn't be applying to
both because their tentacles
might be different let's see the pattern
wouldn't include the tentacles it would
just be the ring that you're interested
in
okay fine i see so so in that case
it's saying it's a region of interest if
it's image processing it will be a
region of interest
which is this is the region of interest
to consider for the alignment
is that correct yes
okay so one point though that um
that i heard bob mentioned a minute ago
and i think
you alluded to also that um so if ref is
a big thing
and it has coordinates and maul is a
small thing it seems reasonable that you
might want to still call it expecting
maul
and you n mall uh is this small thing
that is found within
within life right so in this case
multiple benzene and ref could be that
aspirin over there right
yep so then you might it would be very
easy to
to do kind of a bilateral uh
substructure search if ref is small
and maul is big but ref is in mall then
i allude then i use that alignment and
vice versa
so the one thing that's different in
this scenario is if mold is small
compared with ref
there might there are many results so
that's correct
right so well i mean but we need to do
it
when you give a pattern also um
but the one thing i wanted to point out
there though was so
what happens in the case of where you
have a lot of things that you're
aligning
so where you have this ref and then you
have a whole list of things that you're
aligning to it
in that case it doesn't make sense to
look
so it only makes sense for there to be a
one-dimensional
substructure search so for the case of
molecular line
ref comma list of moles having
ref be the big thing and then the malls
each being little things and you're
looking for an alignment
then it kind that breaks down i don't
understand this at all
yeah let's go through this again okay
let's go through it again
you have for some reason this idea that
the molecules are of comparable size
i do not understand that idea why is it
not the case that what okay so there are
two things you could imagine
you say i've got this molecule
i agree they're different relative sizes
okay so let's go through the scenarios
one scenario is
i've got this molecule it's quite big i
want to know
were i to try to you know where is
geometrically where is this this ring
right how would i align a
fiducial ring to the actual ring in this
molecule
correct that's one thing you want to do
do you agree
yeah okay in that case what you're
returning
is the ring with its
coordinates whatever coordinates it had
before they've been blown away well
actually they haven't completely been
blown away because it is a rigid
transformation that you're doing on it
yes it's a it's a 3d rotation of some
kind
rotation and translation right
and because this is the real world
there's no um there's no scaling
no scaling that's right and no inversion
of symmetry either
okay okay
okay fine so
it's a rigid
you know thing okay but
what you're doing is you're taking that
little ring
which is specified as a molecule and
you are changing its coordinates
right yes okay that's case number one
case number two is
you've got a little molecule first
and a big molecule second right
yep i don't understand why it's not the
exact same thing
you're doing a rigid rotation of the
second molecule
and you just give the results it is it
is exactly the same thing it's just that
the way
jason had set it up first when you don't
supply the mapping
the atoms in the first to the atoms in
the second
it tries to infer what that mapping
should be with the assumption that the
first molecule is a substructure of the
second
we wanted to we thought about using
maximum common substructure
but we don't you know that's not
implemented yet and that
oftentimes doesn't give you what you
want
right so the the
question is um
so you could always call find molecule
substructure
on ref and mole in the correct order and
feed that as the third argument of
molecule a line is that true or not
i think so i i think i understand what
you want there and that's basically you
know
algorithmically getting the mapping
instead of typing it in
however is it going to be the right way
round
it may or may not depending i mean you
know if you just have a generic
six-membered ring it could map
12 different ways no no no no but i mean
right way around
structurally here that is if i say
if i say find molecule substructure
that has the feature that the first
argument is the big guy and the second
argument is the little guy
right yes yes okay so then
the order of the rules that that returns
is big to little
right always big to little
is that right jason when it returns the
mapping
i'm uh checking right now
so let's see so fine molecule
substructure always returns the rules is
little too big okay fine all right
so obviously the right way around but
okay little debate okay yeah it makes
sense okay little too big
okay so what the point that i'm making
is there's
a version of this in which you would
have to say reverse slash at
with respect to these rules to get it
the right way around if you use fine
molecule substructure there
yes you understand what i'm saying
which is a little bit icky
so and you might expect molecule a line
once it has done a substructure search
and said oh uh ref
isn't a substructure of maul but i was
only given two arguments you might
expect it to then say
oh well i could just do the reverse and
see well i think the teacher
look the common common substructure the
largest common substructure is the right
thing to do
in the symmetric case though
you may not be able to do it today but
that's the right thing to do going
forward
isn't it right but then um
yeah then everything gets trickier when
the when you have this
at the list of this the second argument
hold on let me think about that for a
second
um
it is a little tricky in that case not
undoable but a little tricky
and common substructure oftentimes
doesn't return the thing you're looking
at these two molecules and you're saying
it
is clearly this ring it is clearly this
ring why aren't you returning
it and it but it isn't because it's
found
what it thinks is a slightly uh larger
substructure
um
then we need a function that does the
intuitive thing
right you're not going to get away with
that you knew that's going into that i
mean
look if it does something which isn't
what people expect then it's not doing
the right thing
why does it not do the right thing i
mean that is why does it give a
you know you're saying that there is a
subtle way i mean this happens all the
time in theorem proving
where you know which which has the same
issue right you have to be able to match
some particular pattern to some
expression and often those matches
are like you i mean i've spent like five
minutes trying to understand how
it saw that match right in other words
what
got turned around in this way and that
way and the other way to make the thing
match
is that is that the issue that there are
transformations there are
i mean my guess is the reason it will
come up with something which is
non-intuitive to a human
is that there are additional
transformations that get made that a
human does not simultaneously make
so the cases that that jump out of me
are cases where there is a large ring
system and it
didn't it isn't grabbing that whole ring
system because it's
it's found that if it can if it can go
off in this branch
and include this branch it'll actually
make the match
and get a higher score right
if what if it goes out of the r if it if
it
if it creates a linear substructure that
uh that includes this branched pathway
that's exactly the type of thing that
i'm that i'm referring to in the
theorem proven case that it finds these
things which are
which with a little bit of
transformation or something
you know succeed further than the thing
that is the obvious thing
so i bet there's a heuristic to get it
to do the obvious thing
that seems worth thinking about
because it seems useful doesn't it i
mean you don't you know since you're
saying
people want to just say i've got this
molecule i've got this other one i want
to line them up in this way
if it lines it up with some weird linear
thing that it found that was a
weird kind of snake that went between a
bunch of rings
that they're not going to be happy with
that
right and i mean until we get the work
out the kinks in the mcs i mean we can
we can show examples where you use fine
molecule substructure to generate a
mapping
that you feed i mean so not okay so
so i i just went and said uh okay that
we could
include examples where you'd first do
this and then do that um but can we do
that in an example that is
below the fold that is uh you know what
i mean
i'll do that in the application section
jason okay
right and you can do things in the top
section where you say one arrow two you
know whatever and
just don't build up a giant thing where
you're you know
or if you have to try and do it in line
okay stephen um when we don't supply the
atom mapping
and there are let's say two examples
where it could go
uh you know one ring in the other ring
uh
you would want a list to come back in i
don't think so i think you want i
think you want consistent behavior i
would say that
i'm sorry could you i don't know i think
you'd i'm thinking i think you'd want
one of them to come back
but i admit it's tricky case
right i i think so i think of first so
just
sending one back and then we could
possibly issue a message and saying that
the the reference was found multiple
times
i think that's probably not a bad idea
we don't want to
have people but then the question and
then if you want to
and basically say use fine molecule
substructure to find all this
all the substructure instances right
um okay what else do we have to figure
out about this
so um let's see we had originally
thought to to
model it almost strictly along with
image align
but uh the fact that we have to give
this atom mapping
means that uh the the that the
the call syntax is slightly more
complicated and so we need
we can't we need a method to return the
the error
and so that's why we have this uh fourth
argument version
where in the fourth argument you can say
that you want to let's look at them into
lines for a second
let's let's just look at the widget line
you know this behavior just drives me
crazy
so image line doesn't have to return you
back the the transformation functions or
the error
because it can it can pass that off to
find geometric transform
well what it's doing is it's returning
the aligned image right
so in this case it's a big image and
it's aligning to the little image is
that right
i can't tell what the heck this is doing
what is this doing
so it's aligning the second it's
returning a copy of the second
where it's been aligned to the first at
least the way i've read the
yeah if you click on the output you'll
see there's a big
yeah that's where it fits in the frame
of the of the original
[Music]
somebody should make this a bit clearer
in this output
so it is redoing the coordinates of
mall
doesn't this have a region of interest
issue doesn't this have to
say so it has a concept of image key
points
uh you i don't know that you can
specifically provide the mapping in a
very convenient way or that uh
and that that's necessarily what the the
users of the system want to do
no i don't they do typically you know
you can find your own key points and
provide those i've done that with images
but we needed to provide uh give an
easier syntax for that
i mean that yeah that's just our atom
mapping jason
right right
but in image line i think you need
method goes to image key points goes to
rather than having it as an argument
could somebody who's here um
just uh well
okay the um manu yes this this
crazy thing with this um help viewer
john says he doesn't know what i'm
talking about so
could you either send him a fragment of
this recording
like from right then 54 minutes 55
seconds
or ask him to join now but
okay okay i'm gonna just send him
uh do you want him to be in the meeting
not really no i'll send him something
okay
okay uh
okay
well let's see so this thing
all right i think we've talked about
this enough i mean i you know the issue
here the only thing that i'm wondering
about
is
those parts of the reference are aligned
with those parts
whereas this this pattern
refers to what it refers to the
reference molecule correct
well it refers to a part in both so you
find
pat in both maul and ref
okay of which there may be multiple
paths in both ref and mole
correcting what do you do in that case
what i uh and i think it says this here
uh
we take the first result from fine
molecule substructure
okay okay it says if ref occurs multiple
times
the first substrate okay so then this
you should say let's find some molecule
substructure of mole coma ref
or is it ref common mole mol kamar f
which is the other way around
from this
right so um that's not right that's not
right it's not right it's not right
fine molecule substructure is big comma
little right
yes okay this is
also big comma little isn't it
so no so if you don't provide a mapping
it looks for ref to be
in maul okay i think it's the wrong way
around
yeah yeah then the then the
the then this then this multi
uh this list to second argument part
doesn't make any sense
yes well it can jason but generally
that's done when you've got an explicit
mapping and you know what you want to
align
in each of those malls to the reference
you know from drug design this is where
this comes from and we're trying to
handle what i consider
corner cases when the user doesn't care
a damn about what atoms map to what
other atoms
okay but but but so look find molecule
substructure
it's big comma little right so we've got
to reproduce that here we can't have it
be the other way around here
yeah that makes sense
okay yeah so
so this case here is you've got a little
knob that you're trying to attach
everything all these big molecules
are all being attached to that one knob
i'm not quite sure why you need to do it
that way
why aren't you just mapping this over
that you know why aren't you just having
a i mean i don't
see why they all need to be put in this
one function it's not going to do any
different
than just mapping it is it uh yes
um if you do them if you do the
molecules
each one individually against the
reference then you could effectively do
the same thing with map but you can also
do the alignment simultaneously
where all the molecules you're
minimizing the deviation
among them the n times n minus one pairs
okay so you want that's explained
further down in the dark okay all right
fine but then but then for your purposes
if
right but these are the big mo okay
i understand maybe you need both of them
to be able to be lists but if that's the
case
how can this work unless the molecule
okay you get the point it's got to be
big common little otherwise
yeah but then then you're saying
big could be a list of big molecules
correct
no we don't want a list of reference
no general there's just one reference
but the relative size
really does not matter unless you're
trying to do a substructure perception
okay fine but then conceptually this is
big
comma little i mean it might actually be
the other way around but it doesn't
okay go on if you don't provide a
mapping
then you make the assumption it's big
come a little
is is one way to operate yes okay fine
fine then it's the same as fine molecule
substructure
then the way we explain it is it will in
that case
in that first case there it will do a
fine molecule substructure
first and then it will do the alignment
right yes it would do that
okay yeah well the first approximation
that seems reasonable is probably a
little bit more to look at here but
let's keep going
maximum common substructure so is that
something specific to molecules or is
that something that
is supposed to work for any because that
name
certainly it doesn't have the word
molecule in it but it is i'm not aware
of any other
field that's interested in uh
max uncommon substructure i can imagine
expressions being interested
what what did we call i'm sorry find
what was the the thing called find
molecule substructure
i think it should be called molecule
maximum common substructure
i know it's long but i think i think
it's wrong to just say maximum
common substructure and so molecule mcs
would be out
i mean so in the community uh maximum
common substructure is
always followed by parentheses mcs and
then they write mcs in the rest of the
paper
it's not totally out
because that would be shorter i know
it's shorter but there's also auto
complete
sorry
yeah but i think it'd be wrong to not
have molecule in there
yeah think about that go ahead i'm sorry
stephen i was gonna say by the time you
get to molecule max it should
autocomplete
i mean this isn't something where you
have a hundred instances in one piece of
code is it
no it's just it's the one big punch
and then that's that indeed
i should call it molecule maximum common
substructure
okay
molecule pattern represents the largest
common substructure for the input
molecules
by the way you could call it max common
substructure we've done that a number of
times
but i don't know it sounds sounds right
to call it maximum common substructure
i think it should be marking your
maximum common substructure
what is acceptance threshold and by the
way that's a mistake that capital letter
there
no wait a minute
so this is you're getting this from
image identifying those kinds of things
so it's a number between zero and one
correct
right and i mean it was the the
function itself has something uh
something like a threshold and so i
found acceptance threshold and thought
it the concept
matched reasonably well okay seems
reasonable to me
anybody else want to opine on this
molecule mcs versus molecule maximum
common substructure
i prefer maximum common substructure if
you see it in a piece of code you know
what it is
absolutely if you saw a molecule mcs
then you would need to
to open up the dock page to even figure
out what it was
right so um so this would have one new
symbol as an
option match parameters um
there's no way you're gonna have
something thing called match price right
so the i mean the the sub options the
the method options would be match atomic
number
match valence match formal charge and
these are all true or false
and so this was a way of combining them
and you give a list of those things that
you would match
so you could you could perform the match
taking all the
atoms to be equivalent and all bonds to
be equivalent or you could
enforce that uh bond types match or the
charges match
um that's why aren't you just putting
those as a second argument here
i don't know um seems right to me and
considered that
i mean if that's the thing that um
just a bag of those things is the second
argument
i mean when you say bond type that is a
property name
similar to the property names that you
would give for standard molecule
property names right
rate but we don't have all molecule or
like all atom or bond properties set up
in this i understand so there'll be some
which give error messages right now
i mean some which will always give error
messages because they just don't make
any sense
it's like molecular mass doesn't make a
lot of sense to give there
what is atom stereo so that's the uh um
r or s the chiral um but is that the
name that we have for the
is that the name for the property for an
atom no i think atom chirality
is the okay then then that's then that
is what you should use so
so what i would suggest is that the
second argument here
is simply well either i mean i would
suggest
yeah i mean is there no yes
is there an obvious default or is there
so the default that we choose which is
not obvious but uh
seemed reasonable to me was to make
automatic
equal this list atomic number bond type
and ring membership
but it's not clear that that's what
people would want
okay but are there named combinations
that might be useful
not yet um okay but i mean okay
no no i didn't mean that i'm asking in
in the world at large when people ask
for the
you know give me the mcs relative to
what blah blah blah
no okay all right
fine well then i i suggest a second
argument of those things
because they seem kind of critical to
the operation of the function
don't they yes that's what i would
suggest so
you have already find molecule
substructure right
so what shape would the second argument
be a list
then you don't know the order that's
inconvenient
i don't know which order of the list
elements
i don't think it matters michael oh okay
good i sold it
yeah no and if you give just a single
one you know it'll turn it into a list
of one
yeah and all so all of the things in
that uh
table could be made to uh autocomplete
so when you're making a list
yeah oh i know it'll be convenient yeah
okay what's the third argument here how
many times do you want to look
how many up to how many you want to rate
okay well it seems consistent
seems good okay uh jason if you said
five for that and there were only
four would it fail or is it effectively
an update that's up to it says up two
yeah it's set up and you should support
it
actually being the word up to as well
that's a good point i'll make a note
okay so this next part i feel
is might be too immature for 12
3 but i need design input to move
forward
uh in general like what should the api
look like
for this next uh okay so is this like
image key points
no okay it's a feature vector
okay is it running in the system here
can i use it
yeah so those uh those examples that
should work
why do you pick this unbelievably
complicated creature maybe you can just
read that fluently because i have
i have a list of uh um molecule names
that i
that i just grabbed random ones from uh
oh boy because i'm always amused by or
impressed by the fact that opsin can and
i know that it's
going through that and forming the
chemical graph based on the name
and that yeah that always impresses me
okay
okay let's talk about how feature
extraction works
right so feature extraction i mean
there's a lot of
subtlety here because the main issue
with feature extraction is we were very
worried about what
if the algorithm for feature extraction
changes in the future future
do you see what i'm saying yes
fingerprint at the moment where we
mainly have
so far a set of uh algorithms
that are in use elsewhere no i i
understand that i understand it but but
you might want to change them someday
because you know modern machine learning
has improved and you know blah blah blah
so feature extraction
returns a raw vector in the end
i don't know i mean this data structure
thing is entertaining but i don't think
it's especially useful
it does it does present issues um
so so essentially the way that they're
currently used
um and that's not the most useful part
that's a very unuseful part
i mean it's the it's how the bit vector
is stored by the data structure
no no but in our application it would be
great if normal
gave me a list of zeros and ones but
why doesn't it it gives so
it gives the bytes or the the yeah this
is wrong i think you should report that
to the data structure people i think
this is wrong normal should do
you could you should they should have
another accessor that does this normal
should give the bits
i will file that okay
okay let's come back to this so explain
to me how this is used so you would get
some large database
of molecules and you would get all of
their fingerprints and then what
so then you could when you get a query
you can
return those molecules that are most
like it
or oftentimes you might want to return a
set of molecules that are diversely
different from it
okay so for example if i did a feature
space plot with molecules
this will be the thing that would be the
default thing used for the feature
extraction for that is that right
yes i haven't been able to quite
make it that work in my examples uh
and okay so that would yeah in that case
this should be able to be the right hand
side of feature extractor
yes so so the way i um
let's see so if you evaluate molecule
fingerprint the way it is implemented
right now
without a molecule as the first argument
it returns a molecule fingerprint
function
which i envisioned as being the right
hand side for feature extractor
or um molecules why are we even doing
that
why isn't it just a feature extractor
function
here's what i think you know first
my first cut at this would be
um
that um uh
you know you can give it a little
cosmetic
layer that's about molecules and
fingerprints but below that layer
it should fall through to generic
machine learning feature extraction
because then the whole apparatus with
feature extraction and
clustering and you know dendrograms and
all that stuff will just work
you see what i'm saying
so let's see so so we've got the layer
that i build that
can take the molecule and translate it
into the bit vector or count vector
right
exactly and then the machine learning
stuff needs to know just
how to how to get those and uh
no no no no the whole point is it
already has the apparatus to deal with
okay let's say you want to make a
dendrogram you've got a bunch of
molecules you want to make a dendrogram
showing the family tree relationship
between the molecules
right yep so that requires a distance
function and a feature extraction right
is that i think so i'm not sure about
yeah the distance function so
is there in fact a distance function
because there's a feature distance is
there a molecule fingerprint distance
something like any motor similarity
might work
right so i wrote the function molecule
similarity
even though and so i wrote in there's a
note about this on the meaning agenda
how essentially
chemists talk about molecule similarity
they take fingerprints and
compute their similarity and it's right
so i mean
we have many distance functions that are
called such and such dissimilarity blah
blah blah blah blah
yeah and so we could use those
definitely or something like that i mean
so
the point that i'm making is this needs
to fit in so the machine learning
framework
has two kinds of things i think one is a
distance metric between objects
and the other is a feature extraction a
feature vector for objects
now i don't know at what level you
should plug into those things
because the one thing i do think is
correct i mean this
this you know the reason it's called
dissimilarity is because things
that are less similar have a bigger
value
whereas if you call it similarity it
makes it seem like things
if there's a bigger value they're more
similar if you get what i'm saying
right so um
i mean i think it would make more sense
to call it molecule fingerprint distance
or something
because that way you don't have that
confusion what do chemists mean when
they say molecule
similarity they they make the bigger
values mean that the molecules are
further away that's really convenient
no the bigger values are more are more
alike
and generally the scale is zero to one
uh just like
it's basically one minus the dice
dissimilarity or one minus the tana moto
dissimilarity
okay exactly that's what they are all
right so fine so so then
then we panimoto dissimilarity might be
a distance
yeah might be one of our collection of
distances it is
what we have do we have it right now
so we have jaccard dissimilarity which
takes a a list of zeros and ones
uh and can return a okay right
so so those kinds of things like the
jacquard thing if there is a way of
interpreting that for molecules
we should let it eat molecules as well
just as i i'm pretty sure that
things like some of the other distance
functions can eat both strings and
vectors
you got what i'm saying i think most
i'm not sure about strings but uh the
the numeric ones will will take a vector
of uh
zeros and ones and i do
the multi-set uh similar dissimilarity
functions
in the function repository
well hold on hold on i'm saying you can
if there are
dissimilarity measures that both work
for strings and molecules
in the world so to speak then it's easy
for us to take an existing dissimilarity
function
and allow it to take molecules as an
argument that's what i was saying so but
then
uh you need the fingerprinting function
at that point
so of course you do yes you need a whole
bowl of water
so that's why i'm saying jacquard
dissimilarity couldn't shouldn't take
molecule as the first yeah because it
doesn't take images either
but there is an image distance isn't
there
right so i had written the function
molecule similarity which i can easily
change to molecule
molecule fingerprint distance and it can
take two molecules
it can take a method that would tell you
what how to build the fingerprints
or molecule dissimilarity might be
another way of doing it
and so it could and it would it would
also then itself need to take a distance
function option to tell you
because we can compare these these
fingerprints using jacquard using
uh dice euclidean
cosine okay yeah but but okay so hold on
that feels kind of the wrong way around
because it feels like
you know it should be cosine distance i
don't understand why it can't be cosine
distance between two molecules
why isn't that possible it should be we
need to say how to extract the vectors
how to convert the molecule into a
vector right but so so it's one of the
two ways around
either within molecule dissimilarity you
have to give
the final distance or within the
distance thing you have to give the wave
feature extracting for the molecule
right right so isn't there a feature
distance function
based on yeah feature distance here we
go so now feature
distance has a feature extractor
and then what does it find oh there we
go distance function there we go
the distance in the feature using the
feature space so that's that's the
analog so your
your thing would be an example of a
feature distance
where the extractor is your
molecule fingerprint yeah and then
distance function
is one of these jacquard cosine whatever
else it is
yeah makes sense so
this should all plug together i mean
feature distance should be able to take
as an extractor i mean i i don't think
it necessarily needs
a standard feature vector i think it
just
needs i mean sorry i think that it
i don't know whether this needs and you
need to look it up what it needs to get
back from the feature extractor i
suspect it's a list of numbers but i
don't know okay so yeah so i've actually
toyed with a um feature space plot with
these fingerprints and it can and it can
lay them out
and i'd obviously see some kind of
pattern the what i meant by i couldn't
get it to work was i couldn't get the
tool tips to show nice little plots of
the molecules but that's
okay that's a difference yeah right but
i mean so so
what you're saying is feature space plot
feature extractor
arrow molecule fingerprint basically is
what you're talking about
right and feature spacepod also takes a
distance function
which would be the molecule
dissimilarity of
right and then feature distance okay so
so in principle
molecule dissimilarity is a one-liner
that just says okay so i i think
following
um i mean i kind of
maybe it's too long and ponderous but
molecule dissimilarity distance
no molecule dissimilarity is the right
thing i think
i like it okay so then it gets
so molecular dissimilarity
would like feature distance get a
distance function
which is its final cosine whatever
thingy
right yes what to do with the once
you've once you've converted things to
numerical form or whatever their final
form is what
operation do you do right
and so it's feature extractor so its
main
argument structure would have to do with
the way the feature extractor works
okay and then in
what you would do is plug into some of
these other functions like feature space
plot
and learn distribution and so on you
would plug in the default feature
extractor for molecules
would be this thing here yes
um okay sound reasonable to me
now when we have
um
okay does it matter that these things
are bit i mean
it's magnificent using all the data
structure stuff but does it matter that
they're very packed
objects or not
let's see so the bit vectors it can
matter if you have uh
a lot of them it can be nice do you is
that a common thing that you have
[Applause]
it is common to hook these things up to
databases we
i haven't explored uh connecting them uh
so so it's common to use these things in
cases where you have more of them than
you would normally store in your memory
on a desktop computer
okay
just go ahead michael now i don't know
just from emulator
conference at the ufi physics department
yes kinda
they looking up from hundreds of
millions of fingerprints is definitely
an important thing of the future
people agree on this and i was going to
say that
where do you store those where do you
store the fingerprints
so in the in the sql table i think so
they
so and i don't think so because the
lookup there
isn't going to do a very good job it's
not going to give the similarity
distance
there's a cartridge uh and i'm not sure
what a cartridge is because i have i
don't know postgres
but the code that we're using to
generate these fingerprints
has a postgresql cartridge that does
okay so it's like postgres has geo stuff
on it as well
for finding geo distances and so there
it can
find uh do these jacquard and dice uh
distance metrics over um serialized
forms of the fingerprints
but i have not explored that okay so
it's probably similar to the way it does
geo distances
so for us then another function that
we'll eventually have is
is a fine molecule where you give it a
fingerprint or where you give it a
molecule
and it's finding a similar molecule by
fingerprints yes
yes do we not have such a thing already
no we don't okay so there'll be a
nearest molecule or something
so in the i i put some in the function
repository pubchem similarity search
which is a nice wrapper around a service
connect
and it does okay they are doing that
yeah but so
so what this is is like
geo nearest this would be molecule
nearest
yes and it would give you in the
database
just like jionus gives you the nearest
city in a river whatever else
not sure if it does rivers rivers have
always seemed more complicated
um
okay
okay so does this basically answer the
questions right now for
look in terms of the return value for
the fingerprint thing
it's not important that there are data
structures at the moment uh
so i'm i'm yeah i know but the question
is there's an opaque wrapper that comes
back
and
we made the decision for feature vectors
which you could ask the machine learning
team why this was done i remember
long discussions about it probably live
stream discussions would probably find
them
um about why future extraction should
return what it returns and the the big
obsession there was what if a feature
extractor changes
right you have a piece of code
and
there was some quite clever mechanism
for how it stores versioning information
in the feature extractor
okay and but the decision was made there
to return
a raw list of numbers from the future
extractor
i think jason's question was mainly if
the step from the
fingerprint to the fingerprint function
is the right thing
and the other thing at this point when
we had the feature thing we didn't have
the new structures which comes with the
compiler
so this is new functionality with the
bit vector thing which i think is pretty
new
right so i think there's still going to
be a lot of unanswered questions about
fingerprints that the design isn't going
to be quite ready for 12 to
12 3 unless we want it to be very
experimental
i mean because well i agree but i i'm
saying
okay molecule fingerprint
given a particular type of fingerprint
and given a molecule you're going to get
back something
right now you're getting about a bit
vector but you could get back something
different you're going to get some lump
of stuff that is some kind of
fingerprint right yes
okay what is the fingerprint function
supposed to be
it's basically like linear solve
like you frequently want to use the same
fingerprint type on
many many molecules once they make it an
operator form
right so i mean so as i understand it
like you've got feature extraction
which creates a finger feature extractor
function
although in that case feature but that's
because it has learning that's the
reason it does that is because it's it
is
the whole point is that feature
extraction is learning from your
data you're not doing that you do not
need two things
but nearest function linear solve
function it's exactly the same thing
can use it as well no no it is not no it
isn't it isn't it isn't why not
because because nearest function is
taking the particular set of okay
you could have a nearest molecule
function or molecule nearest function
that works like nearest
where you give it a thousand molecules
and it will prep
for you a kd tree or whatever it's
prepping
so that every subsequent molecule you
ask about will be fast that will be a
worthwhile function
molecule nearest okay
yeah but making the fingerprint also
needs a lot of parameters
so also there's a lot of preparation
involved no but i know but it's just
but there's no there's no runtime
preparation
it's just that you you specify
this complicated thing with a lot of
parameters which i claim should be an
operator form of molecule fingerprint
right okay so so that i mean that is
doable into a molecule fingerprint of
just the method will kind of remain
unevaluated
yeah and it can make itself into a blob
if it wants to and then you apply it to
a molecule
it's an operator go ahead said uh
the name molecule fingerprint you might
expect that it itself is a wrapper for
the data type
and not necessarily a function so i had
originally made it
molecule fingerprint function just as
the operator no
absolutely not okay no
no i think what we want to do is follow
what we've done for feature extraction
right so
i i agree that the molecule fingerprint
is is complicated and ambiguous but the
things that are clear
so having a function called molecule
nearest
which works using fingerprints seems
like an obvious thing to do
yep right and it would so what what what
is the head of the
so molecule nearest of moles and then
method goes to
and that's where you put your thing that
is your feature extractor function or
your
that is the the molecule finger the
operator form of the molecule
fingerprint i would think so
i think so and then molecule nearest
would have a one argument form where
you've given a thousand molecules in it
prep and nearest function that you can
then use on individual molecules
right right right okay i don't know a
clever way to do it at the moment
i know that there should be but i know
it's right i have it you just use the
way that nearest does it just use what
nearest does
i think that doesn't work very well in
this super high dimensional spaces
okay fine
fine okay so we are saying the the
similarity to be carrying this for
12 3 and pointing it for a later release
i i don't think we need i mean i don't
know what what what's the deadline
does fingerprinting was always an
offering for the machine learning group
that we can use it in for machine
learning which
is waiting for a long time so right i
mean what is the deadline that is
that is the question so why don't you
put it in as a featured
extractor in the machine learning system
and then putting it in with its own
custom things in
you know with its own custom wrapping
for molecules is a separate thing
but just make it one of the feature
extractors just give them it and tell
them to put it in as a feature extractor
okay then it'll just work i mean that
you know the feature extractor can have
all kinds of weird arguments
that's what feature extractors do so in
doing so do i do i tell them
i mean hook it up to system bacteric
molecule fingerprint which
i mean i don't care what you do there i
mean it's
as far as this is concerned it's just
look i don't know why this doesn't have
a link to the feature
where the heck
where is the list of features of feature
extractions that you can do
oh here it is okay so here's the list
right so
just give them one for molecule and have
it work by default when you give
molecules there
and and i don't know you know again
you should ask them because i don't know
where the extra parameters for these
go do you understand what i'm saying
yes
right but you should just give it to
them so they can hook it up here
and if you need to have multiple names
if you want
of common you know fingerprint methods
that you can give as named things here
like you have multiple spectrograms here
okay and then then then all of our
machine learning stuff will just work
for molecules in the first instance
makes sense
[Music]
and then we can we can loop back and
look at it as a custom thing which has
more bells and whistles later
yeah this sounds good let's try that
okay
great all right i think that we i need
to run after something else here but i
think we got through the main agenda
here yeah
good looking nice thank you thanks yeah
very good okay the old thanks to you
thank you
okay